you can support the david pakman show if
you ever shop on amazon.com and
particularly with the holiday buying
season really ramping up now as we get
closer and closer to the end of December
uh please stop by david pakman.com slash
amazon before you shop and then any
shopping you do will send us a kickback
and i was thrilled to see that over the
last week one of our viewers purchased
the complete calvin and hobbes box set i
have this my dad got this for me as a
gift a long time ago i grew up reading
calvin and hobbes and it's funny now
seeing my little sister who's 12 also
get into calvin and hobbes were you into
calvin and hobbes or was that it is it
not the right generation I think it's it
encompasses all generations but not so
much as a kid when I was a young adult
I'd its breed up some of the dynamics
it's the best and I'm actually that
there's a calvin and hobbes subreddit on
reddit which i'll look at every once in
a while and i still remember every
single strip from when I used to read
them as a kid it's fantastic so
congratulations to whoever bought that
through our amazon link also their uh
somebody purchased a few sort of
positive affirmations audiobooks and
this reminded me of there's a scene in
mr. robot it's either at the end of
season 1 or the beginning of season two
were the portia doubleday character i
think like someone she's seeing
romantically has one of these positive
affirmations CDs or mp3s I don't know
what it is and she starts listening to
it and it starts having this hugely
positive change on her life and I
couldn't help but think of that when I
saw that somebody had purchased some of
those through amazon and you know the
power of that seems to be similar to to
mindfulness and meditation I wouldn't
write off the power of positive thinking
for a lot of people yeah just positive
reinforcement gets you in the right
mindset the most expensive item of the
week purchase through our amazon link a
Diamondback uh mountain bike at six
hundred dollars thank you for that
individual we don't know who it is we
just get a list of products that are
purchased and thanks to everybody who's
been using that link some people for
many years uh some people for only a few
days david pakman.com slash amazon that
is the way to make it so that you're
shopping on amazon.com supports the work
that we do